wenn wir mittlerweile schon durchgebaut
der ist richtig geil geworden und wir
haben Schwert gebaut das ist auch
ziemlich geil geworden allerdings nehmen
wir leider nicht mehr im Mittelalter
deswegen haben wir das einmal noch nie
benutzt also es kann noch nie irgendwie
ein oder so der mir abstechen mussten
bisschen enttäuschen deswegen wollen wir
heute meine Klinge bauen die man auch
actuius und zwar in Küchenmesser ist
irgendwie ein billiges aus dem
Möbelmarkt
liegen
normal für Recherche Zwecken zu unserem
neuen Projekt wir wollen Küchenmesser
bauen und zwar selber dieses Video wird
unterstützt von Anker mehr dazu später
recherchiert
[Musik]
Alter wie viel Messer hast da kam halt
nur Schmutz raus fällt dir gar nicht
mehr
hunderte Messer
erfahren wieso sind die Bilder nicht
ganz
ich habe ihm dann auch versucht zu
erklären was ich gerne framing hätte wo
man das Ganze besser sieht bist du mega
heftig mittlerweile
ja okay
vielleicht ein bisschen besser aus alter
sieht geil ausschaut richtig gut aus
viel geiler aus das heißt geil ich finde
so diese symmetrische Klingenform in die
Spitze so in die Mitte vom Messer läuft
irgendwie nicht ansprechend ach so ja ja
noch unten geneigt von nichts hübscher
also nach oben geneigt dass er ein
bisschen so Outdoor Messer mäßig
bisschen gefährlich ja ja nach unten
entscheiden indem wir stecken wir den
Griff rein so über die Messer oder
machen wir es so europäisch liegen die
Griffschalen außen drauf machen die mit
so Messing stehen fest das europäisch ja
also das zentraditionell japanisch
einfach Loch rein
was eigentlich ganz genauso bauen ich
finde es geil wie das ja aber dann wird
das ja eher so ein Gerät so klassische
japanisch halt schwierig dass wir dann
noch so ein Messingring vorne dran
kriegen ja wir müssen noch irgendwas
machen jeder irgendein Messer bauen und
ganz nach dem Motto haben wir uns jetzt
für folgende Materialien entschieden die
Klinge wird aus speziellen Werkzeugstahl
gemacht weil wie wir aus unseren
vorherigen Projekten gelernt haben
sollte man dafür nicht irgendeinen Stein
nehmen der Griff soll dann zum einen
Teil aus wunderschönem fast schwarzen
Ebenholz und zum anderen Teil aus hellem
Olivenholz entstehen verziert mit
Aluminium und das Modellieren wir jetzt
in CAD Modell
ist nämlich auch
so
Rohling aber er hier er ist halt nur 17
ne aber insgesamt ist der ja okay den
brauchen wir schon komplett ne um 13:30
brauchen
[Musik]
negativ-ding haben mich ganz stark aber
ist auch so eine Kurve dann
das ist erstmal die Kurve machen aber
nur leicht ne das gibt's bestimmt schon
alt Geschworenen Winkel den es einhalten
muss das nicht im japanischen Gefängnis
die Form ist jetzt schon mal echt geil
was jetzt noch fehlt ist die Klinge also
die Schneide schon geil hinkriegen
3 mm auch wie die Klinge
krass mit etwas Inspiration von einem
japanischen Messer dass wir schon zu
Hause hatten ist die Konstruktion fertig
die wichtige Frage ist noch soll das
lange Teil vom Griff aus dunklem oder
hellem Holz sein ich finde es dunkel
weil dann das kurze helles Stück das
direkt bei der Klinge ist dann später
einen guten Kontrast zum geschwärzten
Stahl geben wird in 3D sieht das Messer
jetzt extrem geil aus mal schauen ob wir
das in echt auch so schöne bekommt moin
heute mit meiner Wenigkeit wir haben uns
hier extra
Werkzeugstahl bestellt hier einmal drei
Stück dann habe ich mir ja einmal das
Messer ausgedruckt dass wir gerade am
Rechner konstruiert haben das werde ich
jetzt bisschen grob ausschneiden und
dann werden wir das mal hier so drauf
kleben einfach
ich drücke mir dann wohl noch mal aus
und versucht dass ich nicht diesmal
[Musik]
Aussehen
versucht Nummer 3
[Musik]
dann schnapp ich mir mal das erste Stück
Stahl
[Musik]
es passt perfekt drauf
so machen wir den erstmal sauber
in 11 von 10 Fällen klebe ich mir die
Finger eh zusammen deshalb Handschuhe
Schutzbrille in den Augen ist das Zeug
nämlich auch nicht so geil habe ich
gehört
dann nehmen wir hier bisschen
Sekundenkleber man hat das war schon ein
bisschen
[Musik]
das lassen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen
aushärten und dann ab an den
Winkelschleifer und hier ein bisschen
Brille und absolut sie
das hat doch schon ganz gut funktioniert
hier die Schneide und jetzt machen wir
noch
der passt schon ziemlich gut
funktioniert so das grob auszuschneiden
ich habe hier jetzt noch ein paar so
kleine Unreinheiten da wo ich mir jetzt
bin Winkelschleifer noch eine extra
Schleifscheibe wird das noch mal schön
ausschleifen hier das ist schön diese
Rundung reinkriegen
die sind ein bisschen dicker
[Musik]
fertig mit Winkelschleifer ich finde es
sieht schon fast aus wie ein Messer nee
eigentlich sieht schon aus wie Nüsse
finde ich hier noch die Kanten bisschen
schöner mit Bandschleifer arbeiten hier
noch schön die Rundung und so raus und
dann kann sich das doch schon sehen
lassen glaube ich
[Musik]
jetzt wechsle ich hier noch schnell
Aufsatz auf so einen innen
radienschleifer dass wir hier die in den
Kante noch schön Schleifen können
das ist auch schon angenehm ist am
Finger nur das Messer dann so in der
Hand hält
aber das heißt
10 Minuten schlafen
[Musik]
der Strom den wir gerade verbrauchen
kommt übrigens zum Teil von unserem
balkonkraftwerk die Anker Solex
Solarpanels haben wir schon in einem der
letzten Videos aufgebaut und ich freue
mich dass Anke dieses Video hier auch
unterstützt wir haben jetzt nämlich
zusätzlich noch die neue Anker Solex
aufgebaut bei Solarpanels liefern den
Strom natürlich nur tagsüber wenn es
hell ist aber ihr braucht da zu Hause
vielleicht kaum Strom weil er auch da
weiter die ankersburger Bank will also
tagsüber aufgeladen damit ihr den
Solarstrom auch abends im Dunkeln nutzen
könnt wo am meisten schon verbraucht
wird das lohnt sich auch wenn er schon
balkonkraftwerk hat das nicht von
der Bank ist mit 99% aller Mikro
Inverter nutzbar und ohne sonst
Zwischenspeicher könnt ihr im Schnitt
nur ca 40% der erzeugten Energie nutzen
mit der solarbank bis zu 90 dadurch dass
die den Strom speichert könnt ihr also
mehr als doppelt so viel von eurem
Solarstrom nutzen als ohne toller Weg
was in 15 Jahren Ersparnis von 2.670 €
in der Stromrechnung bedeutet die
Anschaffungskosten also schon nach 5,6
Jahren wieder reingeholt in der Anker
App könnte sogar ganz genau sehen wie
viel Strom gerade produziert wird und wo
genau hinfließt die Installation geht
innerhalb von fünf Minuten einfach die
soulbank Panel und Mikro Inverter
anschließen und schon kann die solarbank
den erzeugten Strom speichern und über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung könnt
ihr nochmal zusätzlich bis zu 100 Euro
auf euren Kauf sparen also den Stahl den
wir gekauft haben der ist leider schon
gehärtet jetzt hätten wir allerdings
gern noch so eine hammerschlagoptik drin
das ist so ein bisschen rustikal
ausschaut und jetzt probieren wir mal ob
wir da überhaupt Hammerschläge rein
kriegen ohne dass wir den zum Glühen
bringen
es geht schon rein aber was Sinn machen
das halt Amazon bisschen warm zu machen
ja so um den weich zu machen musst du
auf jeden Fall so weit machen dass du
halt die Struktur
mehr oder weniger das schon beeinflusst
sonst bringt ja auch nichts also
wenn der glüht dann hat das Gefühl ja
dann musst du ihn danach wieder in Öl
rein bauen lass mal noch bisschen öfters
drauf Dinge so leicht vielleicht nicht
so hart
original nix
Alter das Teil jetzt schärfer werden
wird Alter wir lassen das und ich glaube
damit hat sich das auch
erledigt wir machen das Ding heißt oder
wie jeder normale Haushalt haben wir
natürlich eine Esse und dann kommt
besser dran rein
[Musik]
bevor das Teil jetzt sind die Esse kommt
nehmen wir uns hier noch mal ein
anreißschieber wie die bei uns liebevoll
heißen wieder der eine handwerkliche
Ausbildung gemacht hat weiß dass man die
Dinger nur zum anreißen benutzt wie gut
funktioniert der eigentlich auf
gehärtetem Stahl
ja okay deswegen
nehmen wir uns jetzt Klebeband neben das
hier so grob ab und Fetzen dann hier
einmal ein bisschen mit Schleifpapier
drüber
und jetzt sieht man hier wo später die
Schneide hinkommen soll weil die
Hammerschläge verteilen wir dann nur
hier oben drauf erstmal richtig gut heiß
werden weil sonst für Frauen sich da gar
nichts gesehen hat sondern splittert
einfach nur
[Musik]
Alter
ultra verbogen und die machen jetzt
wieder ein bisschen Plattform
jetzt schon mal grob hier unsere
Schneide zurecht
wird gut
diese Klinge ein bisschen zu entspannen
die ist jetzt quasi geschliffen worden
und war immer so einen spitzen so super
heiß und verschiedenen Stellen und so
und hat jetzt irgendwie intern kam ein
paar Spannungen man soll das jetzt aber
heiß machen oder abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
abkühlt bereite ich mal das Kühlbecken
vor jetzt sind sie mich jetzt gleich
wieder und dann schmeißen wir hier rein
damit das super schnell abkühlt und
tatsächlich ist das zwar gehört
und es ist nicht magnetisch das heißt
das heißt genug und dann wird let's go
ab rein da
[Musik]
woah das erstmal nicht einer wenn du das
riecht einfach nach oben nach so einer
Fischbude Alter ja ja
den Ofen rein ungefähr 200 Grad Umluft
und ja für zwei Stunden
[Musik]
kommt jetzt gerade aus dem Backofen raus
jetzt noch ein bisschen eingebrannt
natürlich noch von vorne soll sie aber
natürlich schon glänzen
[Applaus]
dieser Übergang von diesem rohen
schwarzen industriellen Stahl zu diesem
schönen glänzenden geschliffenen Metall
es sieht so geil aus zusammengebirge das
sieht aber aus wie ein Gebirge in dem
man sich verlieren könnte eine Sache
über den ich mir noch Sorgen gemacht
habe ist auch das mit dem Herten jetzt
wirklich geklappt hat und ja da gibt da
noch einen Weg das rauszufinden und das
wird jetzt für einige von euch ein
bisschen weh tun aber es ist ein Test
und das ist gar nichts
also bei normalen Stahl greift die
Pfeile aber hier macht die Null
geil also jetzt wirklich nicht erwartet
dass das so geil wird ganz kaum abwarten
wie das dann später sich schneiden wird
also von viel her ist es jetzt schon
ziemlich nice ich habe ein richtig gutes
Gefühl bei dem Projekt fehlt noch Griff
und der machen wir jetzt beim Holz haben
wir uns für nicht so ganz traditionelles
Olivenholz entschieden aber wir fanden
und geil und als dunkle Akzent dazu
haben und uns Ebenholz genommen haben
wir so diese hell dunkelkombination die
klassischerweise bei diesen ganzen
japanischen Küchenmessern auch gibt da
schneide ich jetzt erstmal so grob die
Form zurecht und dann brauchen wir den
Griff
[Musik]
das riecht einfach das riecht einfach
komplett nach Olivenöl schneiden wir
noch ein Stück von diesem Ebenholz
runter das ist so hart
[Musik]
das hat auch eine richtig geile Maserung
jetzt schneide ich dir noch auf breite
[Musik]
ich glaube ich schneide das lieber mit
der Hand
[Musik]
das schneide ich jetzt auch nicht per
Hand aus wir haben eine CC deswegen
schmeiße ich das jetzt schnell auf die
CNC
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das kam jetzt gerade raus zu ziehen raus
jetzt kann man sich glaube ich auch
schon so ungefähr vorstellen wie der
Griff später aussehen wird bevor wir das
Verkleben erstmal ein bisschen
anschleifen da haben wir Oberfläche dann
hält hoffentlich unser Kleber besser
[Musik]
ein bisschen
Kraftkleber und ich hoffe der hat genug
Kraft dass der unserer Griff
zusammenhält und der nicht einfach
auseinanderbricht drauf
vermischen wir das hier gut weil so zwei
Komponenten Zeug ist dann schnappen wir
uns das Zeug basteln das einmal hier
drauf ruhig viel sein den restschleife
Weg ja auch noch bisschen was drauf ist
nehmen wir uns die zwei Stückchen hier
pressen da diese Aluplatte drauf
und
dann Schraubzwinge klemmen muss das
bisschen zusammen hier noch oh Gott das
verrutscht die Sau hier noch so
deswegen hier zwingt da Zink
[Musik]
und jetzt lassen wir das Ding 24 Stunden
trocknen
richtig rum zu machen
was den richtig rum deswegen weißt du
was das für eine Arbeit war voll geil
von Gewicht her und ich finde es gut
wird er
mal beides machen was besser also noch
mal in anders rum
[Musik]
zum Schleifen von dem Griff fahre ich
mir eine 3D Druckvorrichtung ausgedruckt
da kann man alles Messer hier so schön
reinlegen und kann dann hier diese
45 Grad Winkel schön anschleifen
das hat mal richtig richtig gut
funktioniert
ja schauen wir mal ob Thomas mehr Glück
damit hat das Problem bei ManU war
scheinbar wie er selber gesagt hat dass
man wenn man hier dran schleift die
ganze Zeit dass dieser alu- äh dieser
Metallteil hier aber viel zu heiß wird
und sich dadurch halt dieser Kleber
irgendwann gelöst hat darum habe ich
jetzt hier so ein Kompressor und macht
aber ja kühle Luft drauf damit es halt
einfach weg geht die Wärme wir konnten
trotzdem eigentlich noch relativ viel
vom Griff retten ich ziehe mir dabei
eine Brille auf weil wenn sie noch mal
so schießt dann
[Musik]
so jetzt ist alles machen
denn das ist richtig geil geworden
perfekt
voll geil
so jetzt kommt buchstäblich der
Feinschliff
[Musik]
hier ist der Griff mega geil also das
ist wie als wäre irgendwie wirklich
professionell gemacht kam nichts sagen
dass wirklich sehr nice das krasse ich
habe in der Zufall eingeschliffen dass
man einfach Wasser drauf tropfen kann
und das hält dann ab bei dem saugt sich
gar nichts rein
[Musik]
hübsch und richtig gute in der Hand
liegen oder auch jetzt komme ich
Hochzeit ja wir machen das pass auf ich
Test gar nicht wir können heute rein ich
muss den Kleber anmischen der Kleber ist
ziemlich böse alles rein ich würde mal
direkt schon maximal dickflüssig
trotzdem versucht mit der Spritze jetzt
mal aufzuziehen und das geht sogar aber
das wird schwierig pass auf folgendes
kurz ab aber falls es daneben kommt ich
muss jetzt ein bisschen beeilen und Pack
jetzt einfach mal hier Kleber rein jetzt
Moment der Wahrheit
[Musik]
perfekt
das ist einfach absolut geil also das
Messer ist komplett krass jo Alter also
ich weiß nicht wann wir das letzte Mal
auf dem Kanal sowas geiles gemacht haben
[Musik]
geil shit
ja man genauso muss man besser aussehen
es liegt aber heftig in der Hand kommen
wir machen mal scharf ich habe mir so
ein Set gekauft mit zwei Schleifstein
der erste kommt jetzt mal rein bei
schiebt man das nicht
[Musik]
ich Google
nächster Stein mittlerweile ist die
Technik noch ein bisschen besser
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt hier einmal ganz viele
Messer vier Stück ein richtig billiges
ich habe keine Ahnung ich glaube das
kostet letztendlich irgendwie 5 € oder
so das hier weiß ich das hat ungefähr 17
Euro kostet glaube ich das hier ist der
Preis Kern weil es ein Geschenk war aber
das ist ein richtig heftiges japanisches
Messer das ein Profi gemacht hat und das
ist ja so ein Messer das
Vollprofi gemacht hat
und wir testen jetzt die mal fangen an
mit dem und das Messer ich hasse es ja
also wir haben das noch aber eigentlich
ich hasse es wirklich eine Gurke
so ich drücke halt schon richtig rein ne
aber ja es geht also schneide das ist
Messer den Tomaten Test ja ganz ehrlich
das ist zur Messe dadurch noch gar nicht
probieren
ja also
nee nee
das nicht schlecht das geht auch die
Gurke easy
ja macht Spaß
das Messer man kann keine Tomate
schneiden das Messer das hier also ich
weiß dass es ins
ne da passiert halt gar nichts man mehr
kaum dass man durch irgendwas
durchschneidet und jetzt auch eine
Tomate
also obwohl ich schon labrik ist geht
easy durch kommen wir zum ein Messer
will jetzt gespannt
ich hoffe es ist scharf es ist hübsch es
ist mega hübsch geworden aber ich hoffe
es ist auch scharf gut nein
ey nice da kannst du einmal drauflegen
man muss noch nicht überschneiden man
kann selber drücken geil das ist übel
scharf hey das ist richtig scharf also
Thema besser ist das auch besser als das
siehst Du man muss immer ein bisschen
hier und da dauert aber hier
geht direkt nice
nee nicht einfach ist das hier ist aber
auch eine andere messerart ja das ist
viel dünner der Klinge Hier und Jetzt
der Tomaten Test der legendäre das ist
das Wichtigste Tomaten sind immer das
Schlimmste zum schneiden
das geht super gut
keine ultra feine Stücke schneiden
krass
[Musik]
wirklich wirklich geiles Messer den Link
zur dieser Schmetterling Alter den Link
zur Anzahl der Bank findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung schaut doch mal vorbei
ich mache mir jetzt den Salat das
wichtigste vergessen mega
[Musik]
funktioniert